якщо то ви і зробив і вони чоловічки від
броні російські солдати без
розпізнавальних знаків occupy вали
український крим анексії півострова
Росії засадив їх тілам і світи тим.
годиною у прокремлівських міді
активно вилазь а пропагандистська
кампанія мытую яко ебола створ аня
атмосфери патріотичної ефіру сир і
населення ви більше націоналізм жарт раз
скрізь і створив цю за мазі російською
столиці і ось ті західні
ті українська пропаганда анти захист від
українська пропаганда
обв'язується страх великої війни в ліцей
страх година тривожність тут але контурі
duis встигнути такий 38 html дійсно
консолідує спільного
добробут завидних сусіди в колиба помри та
для балу тих росіян
про те нині їх не стало не до краю
заходу змінюються в тому числі і через t
як про крим диски телеканали висвітлив
громадян sku вину в сирі та для дачі в
край ритку може бути звірства і
кіфф чиняєв лояльно до сирійського
президента башара асада сили замість ви
їм показують сюжети для героїчних
російських ризикових щастя стена
компанії з ікла але з творить і Росії
образ похилого віку на міжнародній
арені та спорту вати до вколоти росія
більшість російських
вічність російський рамадан Петро і мій
містить політику президента Росії
мультик який здійснюється
президент нарізно нас є скупчення у нас
є купчинь амос лайки до 3 яйця чудову
ідеологію моєму розумінню руку народної
області в нас натиснули травня з божественною
додали хіба що і побоююся ще
конфлікти може зробити щось пак
масштабної війни проте парадоксальним
чином істоти Петро їм ідеї кремля тому
числи і весь килим дарвін собак
діємо телебачення
перемогу розділу на тему опитування
ананда бачимо нарізала doom купу росія
район відповідай на важливу роль
він і думаєте щоб на її одному з
ключових after'll на святій та арені ще
б за її волосся не вишивається жадібно
катує голоси там не наважується жоден
кардинальне питання так і націоналізм на
руку російській біржі цього зараз
ти на полі так і кремля